joining us now dr. deborah birx
coordinator of the white house
coronavirus task force dr. welcome to
Fox News Sunday thank you
where are we with the virus are we past
the peak are we down on the downslope
now and given that just a few days ago
the White House was projecting 60,000
fatalities and we're already up to 66
thousand how many more fatality should
we expect in this country well first let
me start with as we our projections have
always been between a hundred and two
hundred and forty thousand American
lives lost and that's with full
mitigation and us learning from each
other I've had a social distance every
single metro area and every single
outbreak across the country is different
and so whereas New Orleans and now
Detroit and some of our other metros are
showing a significant decline others are
just reaching steady-state we are
encouraged that the New York and New
Jersey metro areas are starting to see a
decline after a long flat curve as we
said about half the date more than half
the states that what started in some way
shape or form reopening but we've
crunched the numbers doctor and not a
single state has met the white house
gating guidelines of two weeks of steady
decline in new cases are you concerned
about this patchwork reopening and and
why leave it up to the governor's why
not set a firm if not binding a firm
national policy on Wednesday --tz-- can
reopen well I think federal guidelines
are a pretty firm policy of what we
think is important from a public health
standpoint we also made it possible for
states to open counties independently of
the entire state because again some of
these outbreaks are very local and have
to be studied and understood that way
and so as States reopened we really want
them to follow the gating criteria but
we also made it very clear to the
American people this
what you need to continue do to protect
yourself you need to continue to social
distance you need to continue to
practice scrupulous hand-washing you
need to know where your hands and where
they have been and what they have
touched and make sure you don't touch
your face and I think most importantly
if you have any pre-existing condition
through phase one and Phase two of any
reopening we have asked you to continue
to shelter in place we know who is a
particular risk for a very difficult
course with this virus and we cannot
emphasize enough how strongly we feel if
you have a coexisting condition to
continue to shelter in place but clearly
when you leave it up to individual
governors and governors are not
observing that the two-week decline
before they open that sends a very mixed
message to a lot of those individuals
you're talking about appealing to I want
to play something that dr. Anthony foul
to your colleague on the task force said
this week here it is we give the
governor's the opportunity to be very
flexible but you have to have the core
principles of the guidelines
you can't just leap over things and get
into a situation where you're really
tempting a rebound
do you share dr. foul cheese guidelines
about this patchwork reopening that some
governor some states are jumping the
guidelines and risk a rebound we made it
very clear that the guidelines are based
on very strong evidence and data and
that is the way dr. Falchi is also
driven we want to make sure that every
individual every employer and every
person knows how to keep themselves safe
in this situation we've made it clear
what the gating criteria is and we've
asked every governor because I know
they're also concerned about every
single person in their state we've asked
every governor to post on their website
and on a dashboard where exactly they
are in the gating criteria but also to
make all the information available to
the public and to have sites
sophisticated sites like Florida does
and many other like Massachusetts stuff
so people can see where the virus is in
their community because an educated
community can really take actions
understand how to protect themselves
well let's talk about how educated some
of the communities are I want to do a
lightning run quick questions quick
answers about some of the activities
that people are engaging in around the
country first of all California where
this past week thousands of people were
massing on beaches and very close
quarters simple question is that safe if
it's done with social distancing yes if
it's not done with social distancing no
well yeah I don't know that you can see
the video there was no social distancing
which is one of the reasons the governor
shut those beaches all right let's talk
about a different issue because we're
seeing a lot of Governors opening up
things like beauty salons and spas where
people come into very close contact
you're getting a haircut you're getting
a massage with each other question if
both sides both parties are wearing
masks is that safe it's safer but we've
made it clear that that is not a good
phase one activity and I think the
president's made that clear when he
discussed the case in Georgia well you
know that's happening all over the
country right now let me ask you about
one more activity big crowds of
protesters that went into the Michigan
State Capitol without masks massing
together in close quarters I'm not
asking you about their First Amendment
right to protest that of course they
have but from a public health standpoint
is that safe it's devastatingly
worrisome to me personally because if
they go home and infect their
grandmother or their grandfather who has
a comorbid condition and they have a
serious or very or an unfortunate
outcome they will feel guilty for the
rest of our lives so we need to protect
each other at the same time we're
voicing our discontent let's talk about
remedy severe the FDA gave emergency
approval to use of this drug to help
people who have the virus is it a silver
bullet in terms of reduce
sing lethality keeping people from dying
and also in terms of side effects
well first it's only half the data and
the data safety modern award an
independent group thought that the
improvement was compelling enough and
significantly enough to actually say
that they couldn't continue the trial as
it was and the placebo arm had to
receive the effective drug so it's a
first step forward in parallel we have a
whole series of therapeutics including
plasma and also monoclonal antibodies
being worked through we are come we
aren't concentrating on vaccines as well
as therapeutic bridges to ensure that
the American people can do well with
this virus eventually we really want to
ensure there's both therapeutics
available and vaccines available rapidly
then there's operation warp-speed which
is the Trump administration's effort to
try to develop a vaccine by next January
now you and dr. Fauci have talked sort
of the rule of thumb is 12 months to 18
months that would be considerably
shorter than that timetable next January
is that realistic the way that is
possible is if you bring forward five or
six different classes of candidates
which the operation warp-speed has done
and so it's not relying on a single
vaccine platform it's relying on several
different candidates that are made
differently and act differently and then
it's about doing compressed phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 trials in an overlapping
way moving forward when you have a good
safety and image Anisa T data but not
with the level of pauses that are often
present in vaccine development and so on
paper it's possible it's whether we can
execute and execute around the globe
because you also for phase three have to
have active viral transmission in a
community in order to study its efficacy
finally doctrine I got about a minute
left there is a new report out of
Australia this weekend that five
intelligence agencies including the US
have put together a dossier that
indicates that the Chinese government in
the early stages either hid work covered
up the fact of the Khurana
and it's spread in Japan I'm not going
to ask you to comment in any way on
intelligence but from a public health
standpoint did the lack of transparency
from China in the early days in
january/february even into March did
that slow down the public health
response in this country wherever that
first jump occurs whether it's from
animal to human or lab to human it
doesn't really matter whoever wherever
that happens you have to over
communicate because that's the that's
when you get the first instance of how
transmittable this virus is what are the
people that it's particularly
susceptible to that didn't happen and it
didn't happen until late and you know it
didn't happen until mid January that
they even talked about human to human
transmission and that really when you
see how many countries now are infected
that did fan the virus across the globe
dr. Burks
thank you thanks for your time during
these very busy days and doctor please
come back